Amami Oshima is an island off the coast
of mainland Japan and while it's well
known for its thriving coral reefs and
sandy beaches its sumo that puts this
island on the map Amami Oshima takes
great pride in raising young boys to
become some of the country's best
wrestlers ataxia Mori Kazuo you know
Cimino smoke Roberto Clemente te mo
Shiro
Dozier mo Contra Costa Mesa so snake o
poder so optical depending synaptically
tada in autumn with over 150 dokey O's
or sumo rings
Amami Oshima has the highest
concentration of sumo facilities in
Japan making the sport accessible to
most young people on the island
baccarat
Lee Scott how to do this small walks
they must to take one corner to do
detail into
[Music]
he's gone
underneath chaos dead dogs dead serious
Philip but sumo is not only practiced as
a means for future success it's an on to
the islands history and has been
embedded in its culture for hundreds of
years
[Music]
annual festivals include sumo
tournaments where wrestlers come out to
participate horn and sight you know very
much their Amiga - guru-murthy go - AHA
this motor eaten raw in cascara no it's
lettuce that we must know their chief
academic ah - nama demo minnetonka
Theory gives this but despite the
islands efforts to maintain sumo as a
cultural staple the sport has begun to
decrease in popularity among young
people
I will kilometres ahead take students at
all chief I should have clean air even
our hula so we must area type with
instead
modern II did until the bouquet
cigarettes
Medusa musical knowledge is inaudible on
our radar ni below Isis did a morning
after math me
[Music]